[Music]
i am mark daniel nelson here with make
my music
i have a song here by the artist brandon
barty that i'm mixing currently
and it made me think about sharing this
acoustic guitar
template for when i'm mixing acoustic
guitar
in digital i come across a lot of issues
one
is i seem to never be able to get it to
sound like the way i get it when i get
it on
analog tape even when i'm mixing it with
analog
tape saturation and stuff it's not doing
the overall collective of what i hear
analog tape does to acoustics i feel
that with tape
the acoustic guitar is really magical
sounding and in digital
you get this punch and this brightness
and sharpness in the transient
but it's really hard to tame and
sometimes compressing it too much
or over compressing it will add way too
much artifacts
and it'll sound flat and pumped and just
not very exciting
so i've applied a handful of techniques
to
a chain of plugins that is
in combination allowing me to get a very
similar sound that i get when i
track acoustic guitar on tape i want to
dive in a bit
and show you a little bit of the song as
is with the acoustic chain i have now
then i'll reassemble the song
without the chain and we can talk about
what i did
[Applause]
where
let's dive in a little bit and see what
we got under the hood of the acoustic
guitar
now in my chain here what i'm trying to
do
is tame the transients the
aggressive as an acoustic guitar
being a very percussive instrument
you're trying to make sure that you're
not getting
too much of the overall
spikiness and sometimes when you're
making an acoustic you get a lot of that
emphasis on the spike so i want to tame
that in a pleasing way
a little bit of compression not too much
because that will completely destroy
the entire integrity of the sound of the
acoustic
so you want to create a almost a
color with compression then a transient
shaping
element and then maybe a little bit of a
tape saturation thing
that will cause a little bit of the
warmness of it
and then maybe some dynamic eq
at the end or in the middle depending on
where you're at to tame some of the
low beefiness and some of the top
information
of it let's open this up the first
plugin i like to use
on acoustic is this soft tube
tape plug-in the reason why i like it is
because inserting it into
the channel it doesn't sound nearly as
aggressive as a lot of the other tape
plug-ins by chance i plugged this in as
an
accident and i just ended up falling in
love with it on acoustic guitar
i'm going to take off everything and
solo the acoustic and just listen to it
in and out
the cool thing about this plugin is it
lets you
see and meter what the thd is doing
which is the
harmonic distortion and the element of
what it's doing
to the track and it almost reads as if
it's a compressor
so it shows you how much it's taking out
you can put the color in a little bit
more
or out you can change the type of tape
these a little more mid-range change the
tape speed which will help
change the eq curve a tiny bit in
general i just want to just add a little
bit of glue
it's very subtle that's out
it just pulls the acoustic guitar up a
little bit and
makes a little more forward now after
that
i feel like okay i want to add a little
bit of eq i want to add a little bit of
body at the bottom end
i want to take out a little bit of the
boominess that's around 280
and then i want to do some of this
shelving top band stuff
which will help tame some of the
harshness and then after that compress
it
tighten it up and then the final thing
is to bring in the transects by
waves and take a little bit of that
harsh clickiness
not too much but enough to tame it where
it ends up falling into the master chain
in a very pleasing way
so let me take out the eq and put it
back in and hear what it does
that's with it
taking a tiny bit there
a lot of that shrilly harsh stuff
sounds real nice and pleasing let's pull
in the compressor next
i'm doing this with level but i'm also
adding a just a tiny bit of compression
maybe at the very loudest a db it's
probably my favorite compressor and
setting for acoustic guitars
[Music]
now you can hear the reverb on the
acoustic and that
is uh the abbey road plate this guy
right here
i just have a little bit going into that
feed and it sounds really good it makes
it sound really warm and natural
the last thing i want to do is take some
of that harsh
clicking just so it smooths it out a
little bit
now this is such a fast transient thing
it works very different than a transient
designer
the transient designer seems to be able
to get stuff to be really punchy
and take a little bit out but it doesn't
seem to work as fast as
the transax does that's why i like to
use this on acoustic guitar and kick
drum
[Music]
let's hear it in the track
see how it sits in front of the vocals
now the other thing to consider is to
know that when you're dealing with
acoustic guitars sometimes you're
playing really aggressively and really
hard
and the track can be really dense and if
you can't hear things certainly
you want to compress it more to get it
out in front now if there's
synthesizers and drums everything going
at it
compressing it a little harder is
obviously what you need to do
so just make sure that you go within
reason what your taste goes with
but try to add things in little steps
instead of adding
a ton of things on one issue now i've
basically done a lot of compression
with three different ways one is a tape
one is eq with multi-band
one is an actual compressor doing
compression of the overall content
and the other one is hyper focus on the
transient
of that and they're all kind of ducking
things as a percussive
element like acoustic guitar or drums
you need to be able to be really precise
with what you need to hear instead of
just plastering a big compressor over
everything and hitting it five db
you're losing a lot of that momentum a
lot of that dynamic
and by doing it in little areas you're
hitting it really hard
that's pretty much it i will share these
presets with you guys so you have a
little bit of an idea to start with
just have fun with the plugins